i would ask you to direct your questions
through me
if you could start by telling me what
media outlet you're from and your name
apologies i don't know all your names at
this stage please note that the
questions and answers should only be for
louise tideswell and stuart harness at
this time
cricket scotland and running out racism
will answer questions
in the one-to-one media briefing post
event
so without any further delay i will hand
you over to louise tyswell managing
director of plan for sports
scotland
good morning everyone uh welcome to the
press conference thank you for coming
thank you for wanting to
hear the response to the review this
morning
my name is louise tidwell i'm the
managing director of plan for sport
and we were commissioned by sports
scotland to undertake an independent
review into racism in scottish cricket
i'm here today to talk you through the
findings
and to share with you what we believe
are the correct next steps and
no doubt stuart will also be able to
answer some questions around the next
steps that we're expecting to see as a
result of this review
so
here we are today
25th of july 2022
and we're reporting directly to sports
scotland on our findings and we have
heard from many many people in terms of
their experiences
of racism and indeed other forms of
discrimination
and it's been incredibly difficult for
people to share those experiences
we as a review team at plan for sport we
absolutely recognize that
and we connect with that and we've spent
a lot of time listening to people's
stories some of those people have shared
stories over multiple hours with the
review team and that's been needed
and that's been vital from the re from
the review team's perspective to be able
to hear those stories in detail to let
people relax into that conversation and
to go to places in those conversations
that perhaps on some occasion and one
individual stands out for me that spoke
to me directly he had never even told
his wife he'd never told his family so
sharing those experiences have been
incredibly difficult for many many
people
and that's why we want to place on
record our absolute thanks to the
bravery of those people who've come
forward we recognize for many how hard
that has been and of course we also want
to thank the hundreds of people who've
responded to the independent review via
surveys and i'm going to talk to you
about the surveys in a second because
that's been a real opportunity for
people who still lack confidence to
speak to an individual or to the review
team face to face it's presented a
provided us with a fantastic opportunity
to hear people's experiences
in an anonymous environment
people's commitment to engage with this
review
has absolutely enabled us to report
directly to sports scotland on what
needs to happen next
but i also want to place on record the
fact that there are many many clubs
around scotland there are coaches there
are umpires there are volunteers working
across the game we've spoken to a number
of them in club environments they're
doing fantastic work i'd go a step
further actually i'd say they're doing
outstanding work in terms of ensuring an
inclusive environment for anybody in the
local community that wants to come and
engage in cricket
i think it's incredibly important that
those areas of good practice
those people out there who are really
working hard putting hours and hours of
volunteer time in to create that
brilliant space for people to play
cricket safely and inclusively they
should not be forgotten
in today's headlines
so i'd like to take you through the
stages of the review and this review as
many of you will know and will have read
in the report itself has lasted six
months um so we were commissioned by
sports scotland just before christmas
did a lot of planning work during the
christmas period and the independent
review commenced on the 3rd of january
the one of the first things we did is we
recognized we needed to look at policies
the desktop piece
really important for us to understand
what's in place already and how does the
organization operate both cricket
scotland and policies uh the cricket
scotland push out to its regional
associations for example
and we need to look at those policies
and processes and procedures through
three specific lenses we are looking to
see whether or not those particular
aspects of qriket scotland work that
policy and process piece
does it amplify good practice when it
comes to racial
inequality does it tackle racial
inequality within those spaces
how does it amplify good and best
practice when it comes to equality
diversity
and inclusion you might hear me refer to
edi during the course of this press
briefing equality diversity and
inclusion is what i'm referring to
and all those policies and processes
good practice in the context of hr good
business practice good solid foundations
from which an organization is able to
operate effectively
so we've looked at qriket scotland's
policies we've also we've also looked at
the regional association's policies i'm
sure you'll be familiar with the fact
that cricket's got
five regional associations that covers
the whole jurisdiction of scotland in
terms of managing the game at a regional
and local level
so we worked our way through that and
have worked our way through that for a
number of months to be able to get
through all of those policies and
procedures that were shared with us
there's another part to our review work
and this is about consultation
this is about an opportunity not not
only to allow people to speak to the
review team
but also to invite people specific
groups of people that we feel have a
real opportunity to contribute to these
outcomes
so we've
invited and interviewed board members
and council members during the course of
this six-month window
we've spoken to cricket scotland staff
members
about their experiences
we've also spoken to the scotland men
and the scotland women's team and of
course we recognize that the scotland
men's team are busy preparing for events
later this week and we've also spoken to
the high performance staff the coaches
and all of the colleagues that wrap
around the high performance environment
that was important to get a sense check
policy is one thing
people would tell me it's a piece of
paper louise if it's not implemented
effectively what is the point of the
policy
and they're absolutely right
so the consultation piece bringing this
to life was a really important part of
our review process
case
management i would say this was the
absolute vital line of inquiry
this presented
people out there
passionate about the sport
to come forward through a confidential
means to share their experiences with
the independent review team
and the disclosures that we received
were far and wide
in terms of examples of racial
discrimination and to be fair people
also citing other forms of
discrimination naturally today we are
focused directly on racism within
scottish cricket
the good news and i'm delighted to be
able to say this is that sports scotland
recognized our our work in providing
people with that confidential space
cannot be shut down today
it cannot stop there are too many people
who are likely to see the outcome of
today's report and review and perhaps
feel that they need to come forward and
speak to the review team in that
confidential space
nothing like that exists
within qriket scotland at the moment i'm
delighted to say therefore that sports
scotland have agreed that that's
opportunity to speak to the review team
the plan for support review team remains
open beyond today and there is no
closing date on that and that's entirely
up to sports scotland to decide when it
will be appropriate to stop that
opportunity
where we have needed to
when we've heard those disclosures and
we've needed to make referrals
on to an organization that will
investigate and i just want to be really
clear here
we are not investigators
we have heard those stories created
those safe spaces
we believe that we've
created as an opportunity for people to
share their experiences and been
incredibly compassionate in listening to
those experiences
but there is no doubt that there have
been uh pieces of information and
evidence shared with us that need to be
passed on to professional organizations
who can instigate and undertake
investigations
so yes we have passed information on to
be investigated by police scotland
yes we have passed information on to be
investigated by children
first and we have passed information
back into cricket scotland to be dealt
with by a separate arm which stuart's
going to talk about in a second
to pick up on poor practice and other
referrals in relation to racism and
discrimination
so every single piece of information and
evidence that has been shared and
referred into the plan for support
review team if it's needed a referral we
have referred it on to the agencies that
can investigate
what we also recognised is that we
cannot expect everybody to be willing to
come and talk to us happy to talk to us
want to meet somebody on a zoom call
unfortunately which is the way it's had
to be over the last six months
we absolutely recognize that some people
want to contribute to the outcomes of
this review anonymously
and that was really important a really
important space
what we've got
is an opportunity to do that we
organized launched an online anonymous
review of racism in scottish cricket
we also pushed out a getting to know you
survey about a month later the first
survey concentrated very much on
people's experiences of racism
and if they wanted to share other forms
of discrimination in scottish cricket
the second that you see there uh the the
getting to know you survey was actually
about trying to get a sense of the
diversity and the profile
of people involved in cricket in
scotland unfortunately cricket scotland
could cannot give us accurate data
currently on what that on what that
profile looks like so we needed to go
and do our own anonymous survey to be
able to get a benchmark a starting point
from which actually cricket scotland
year on year could roll out that survey
and be in a position to demonstrate
whether they are having and seeing
positive impact in the diverse changes
of people being involved
in the game
what we've also done
in terms of people who referred
themselves to us that wanted to speak to
the review team we've taken a a sample
if you like of their diversity and what
i can tell you this morning is that
there is an incredibly balanced set of
data there between within those
participants it's around 50
people who are white and 50 people who
are non-white who have spoken elected to
come and speak directly to the review
team
in our opinion that's good because it
doesn't imply there is bias in the
findings and bias in the review team
recommendations
so here we are today and we committed to
publish the high level outcomes through
sports scotland we committed to give the
information to sports scotland
late july we're here today to be able to
share what we believe needs to happen
next
i wanted to share some numbers with you
before we go into we go into the final
recommendations if i may and i recognize
and appreciate that people will have
seen these numbers within the overall
report but we've had almost a thousand
direct engagements in the independent
review from across the whole
of cricket
direct engagements that might be louise
tideswell contributing on three
different occasions to this independent
review or it might be one person
contributing once but we've had a
thousand direct engagements what we have
had is 68 individual referrals
68 examples and experiences that have
related to referrals of which 31 of
those are allegations that relate
to racism
against 15 people
one regional association
and two clubs
what we've all also picked up through
the data and through the surveys the
three surveys is that actually
anonymously
122 people
were willing to share with us that they
had experienced discrimination on the
grounds of race and that 49 people had
also experienced discrimination on the
grounds of religion and belief now
that's anonymous data so we can't track
that back to people's individual names
we could only track the referrals um
which i'm which i'm speaking about there
the 31 allegations
but what's particularly interesting from
the review team's perspective
perspective is that's a lot of people
who are saying that they have experience
to witness discrimination playing the
game um
over however long they've been involved
in cricket
so again more reviewing numbers 171
direct participants have come to speak
to us or have been invited to speak to
us some of those include former players
and former staff of cricket scotland
which has been very helpful because that
gives us some backstory some background
context to
people who've perhaps worked for the
organization two three four five even
six years and longer we've spoken to all
five regional associations and thirty
clubs a geographical spread across the
whole of scotland to get a real nice
perspective on
examples of racism experiences of racism
how those organizations regional
associations and clubs manage incidents
of racism effectively
and we've also had a real opportunity to
speak to different stakeholders and
heavily engaged in this conversation one
example of whom of course is running out
racism
um so just a quick heads up on the
numbers 325 people responded to our
anonymous uh online survey our anonymous
review of racism and scottish cricket we
had more people who responded to the
getting to know you survey 371 people
and that's a real positive data set to
be able to get a sense of what is the
diversity in cricket in scotland
currently
so we were tasked with the question does
racism exist in scottish cricket
and the review team needs to be able to
answer that question and everybody's
expecting us to answer that question
and so where the review tim needed to go
to is what what is the cornerstone of
institutional racism by way of
definition
and so we have used we've elected to
choose and take with us the macpherson
definition
of institutional racism and you can see
here it's the collective failure of an
organization
to provide an appropriate
and professional service to people
because of their colour
culture
or ethnic origin
it can be seen or detected
in processes
attitudes
and behaviors really important point
which amount to discrimination
through
unwitting prejudice
ignorance
thoughtlessness and racist stereotyping
which disadvantages
the phraseology here is
minority ethnic people
so that was the review starting point
high level definition what is
institutional racism we've been tasked
with answering the question does racism
exist in scottish cricket and what we
needed to do because um there is no
framework
that would allow us to map all of the
feedback that we got from those multiple
sources i've shared with you this
morning no framework that allowed us to
map across
to be able to answer that question
directly so what we've done
excuse me
is alongside that umbrella
that umbrella phraseology and that
umbrella definition rather from
mcpherson what we have done is we have
developed our own
plan for sport framework of indicators
of institutional racism
and that has been driven by
data insight
research
all of the sources are in the report
you'll be able to refer directly to
those should you choose to and should
you need to
what's come out of that is 31 specific
indicators now i'll give you a couple of
examples for example what would good
look like in an organization
we feel good look good would be that
leadership clearly leads on leadership
leads on and is accountable for tackling
racism
we'd be looking to see that there is
transparency and it's evidence in or in
decision-making at all levels
we'd also be looking to see that people
from ethnically and culturally diverse
communities are in positions of
authority
decision making
and leadership
that's three of 31 and i respect the
fact that everybody's got the report so
you can see the 31 in detail so we've
got the umbrella mcpherson definition
we've got those 31 indicators that sit
underneath
and so having pulled together
all of the evidence that we've heard we
have assessed and reviewed everything
that has been shared with us
and we have mapped that
against what we are referring to as the
plan for sport indicators of
institutional races and those 31
separate and if you like
elements that sit under that overarching
definition
cricket scotland has failed in 29
of those 31
indicators
so the the review would conclude that
the processes
attitudes and behaviors of cricket
scotland
meet the mcpherson definition
of institutional racism
we are also mindful
that there is as we as we sit and stand
here today
referrals in the system that need to be
concluded that need to be investigated
and subject to their outcome
this may lead us and i emphasize the
word may this may lead us to conclude
that institutional racism
exists in other areas of the game
but let me be clear we are not saying
that today
we are reporting today around cricket
scotland and the fact that it fails to
meet 29 of those 31 plan for sport
indicators
so
we have three key recommendations
the first one of which there is a number
of bullet points underneath and you'll
have seen that in the report
cricket scotland is immediately placed
into special measures by sports scotland
plan for sport cannot do that we are
reporting our findings to sports
scotland sports scotland will choose
what they
will choose what to do with those
findings of course but our
recommendation is that qriket scotland
is placed into special measures
immediately
our second recommendation
is that the western district cricket
union one of those five regional
associations that i referred to earlier
in the briefing
is also placed in special measures they
have to be placed in special measures by
cricket scotland
with immediate effect
and our final recommendation
is that cricket scotland addresses the
backlog
in the referrals that have been
generated
as a result
of this review
and my final slide is about
where do we want to be
what does the future look like
for cricket scotland
and i think it's really important that
whilst the review sets out some
challenging
targets and expectations
based on the evidence and based on the
data that we've heard
and witnessed
we also need to be able to paint a
picture of what good looks like in the
future we also need to be able to lead
cricket scotland to think about
how can we be good what progress can we
make what do we need to look like in
order to not be defined as
institutionally racist based on the
mcpherson definition and so we're giving
you
seven
key long-term outcomes
what does good look like
incidents of racism are managed
effectively
there's effective governance on
anti-racism and edi
there is visible leadership
on anti-racism and edi
and there's a diverse workforce
this is what good looks like
there's an inclusive culture
within the organization within the sport
and inclusive delivery as well and
finally
we recognize that that has to extend
across all areas of cricket so there is
more diversity in the in in high
performance cricket
so we hope that with those short-term
immediate actions and those long-term
recommendations and i can't give you a
timeline on how how long it might take
for any organization to achieve
long-term outcomes but we hope that we
have set in place
a journey that if cricket scotland with
the support of sports scotland
are willing to take
they absolutely one day will be
recognized
as an anti-racist organization
thank you
uh police uh james matthews scout news
can i ask can you
quantify what has been reported to
police
how many individuals
how many allegations
yeah we're not able to at this time
confirm any detail around that
particular film you'd respect that's a
confidential referral
james questions and at the end the
presentation if it's okay
thank you can i introduce you to stuart
harry's chief exec of sports scotland
louise thank you very much um for that
presentation
thank you very much for
creating the report which we've now
received in detail
thank you also to you and your team for
giving us a high level uh
preview of
the recommendations
that we will
implement and so i really appreciate
your team
the in-depth work that's taking place
and i'll refer to some of that and what
i'd like to do is break my con comments
down into the two areas a little bit of
context
and also the mechanics of how we will
implement
the report so thank you again from that
perspective
i'd like to start with recognizing um
the courage of chasm sheikh and majid
hack in speaking out
and telling their story as individuals
but also talking about the systemic
failures that they could see
that let them and potentially others
down
i believe that
chasm and magic magid
gave a lead
to the community
for them to have the courage to speak
out
and
as louise has pointed out they did this
in big numbers
and
i thank them for doing that
for having that courage first up because
this must have been a very difficult
situation for all of them
but they have been listened to
and their issues
recorded
we
once majid and kazam had spoken
we very quickly talked with wider
stakeholders in the sport of cricket
we concluded very quickly that there
needed to be
an independent review
into this issue
we spoke
with stakeholders in that time
and we also announced very quickly on
the 8th of december
the independent review would take place
and then have appointed plan for sport
on the 14th of december uh very early in
the new year we managed to have a
conversation with all of the
stakeholders including running out
racism
to engage at the beginning with the
expectations
for the review
um at sports scotland we've also engaged
with
key stakeholders
partners
in parallel to the review
taking place and i think that's been a
really important
facet of the work
that we've undertaken and finally in
terms of context
we have a strategy called sport for life
is fundamentally built on equality and
inclusion
these were the principles that were
given to us by
our stakeholders and our partners in
scottish sport and we've embedded that
into sport for life which we launched in
2018.
we want and we'll continue to work with
all of our partners to implement that so
that anyone and this is the key outcome
of sport for life anyone who wants to
participate in sport can do so
in an enjoyable and welcoming
fashion let me give you
my reaction
to the report
so we welcome the report we accept the
report we accept all of the
recommendations
immediate action for us will be to place
as a priority
the conclusion of the referrals and the
investigations that
need to be concluded
we will offer
independent expert support
to that process
and we will
ensure
that cricket scotland own the overall
process because it is right and proper
that they do so and ultimately as in any
sport
the future responsibility for this kind
of process should lie
with the governing body
the 15 month period that the louise
talked about um through to october of
next year
we
want to see from qriket scotland
how they will address institutional
racism
by implementing all of
the recommendations that have been
listed
we wanted to create a vision for the
sport
that is more open and welcoming
they need to build a governance and
leadership system that is transparent
and offers that governance in leadership
that everyone's clear
about
and i want them to engage
with communities and individuals
who at the moment feel excluded and feel
that they cannot participate
in this sport
that they love
let me talk a little bit more now about
mechanics and how how this this will
work um some of you will know that
sportscon invests
heavily in some sports and others not so
so much uh
investment which is against outcomes and
that and that outcome is primarily
engaging people in physical activity in
sport at the level that they wish to
participate
we condition that
investment
if required
and in this case we will hold cricket
scotland into account
by ensuring that key outcomes
from the review
are conditioned against the investment
that we will look to award
in order to complete
this 15 month period
in the very near future
there's a lot of work to do
and we understand that
but
it is absolutely imperative that this is
successful
and the terms and conditions against
that investment and let me be clear if
that's not successful it'll be a very
difficult conversation about the status
of that investment
going forward
on the other side
of the coin sport scotland's job is to
build capability
capacity
confidence in our governing bodies and
our other key partners
to do the job that they're tasked with
which is looking after the sport that
people love
across a whole range of different
types and variations of sport and that's
critical if we're going to increase
levels of participation and ultimately
be successful on that world stage
although that's a small part of the
bigger picture
it will be important that we
also as sports scotland use the
recommendations to look at what we're
doing
we use it to
talk to our key partners and
tomorrow i have a conversation with
ceos of
approximately 25 other governing bodies
and senior staff to brief them with
louise
about the recommendations about the
implications and about the mechanics
with which
we will take that forward
i'm also engaging with gordon arthurs
the interim ceo of qriket scotland on
wednesday to begin to build that plan to
build the actions
and make sure we've got the timeline
and resource in place and clear
in order for that to be achieved
in the timelines
that
are recommended
so there's
much to do
to conclude
um
i thank louise and our team at the
beginning and i thank them all again
i also thank
again majid
and kasim for
speaking out alongside all of those
individuals i was also struck by the
commentary that louise offered about
the passion the commitment
that people in cricket across scotland
showed in talking to the review group
and for me
that is a joy to behold because it gives
us hope for the future of that sport
this is their sport
this is the sport that belongs to the
people of scotland who want to play
cricket and i think it's important to do
that
to finish just a couple of
final statements for me
um people have had the opportunity to
speak and tell their story
and they have been listened to
lessons are learned
and will be
and
the lessons will help us to make
improvements to the system what happens
going forward from today
is the most important thing
so that more people in the black and
asian communities and other ethnic
minorities can feel that sport generally
but also in this case cricket is
accessible
to them
we want to create a future where
everyone is welcome
in wider sport from our perspective a
sports scotland but in cricket's case
that's what we want to achieve also
and lastly there is
in our view no place for racism of any
sort
in sport
or society so thank you again
and thanks to you for listening
foreign
james i'm i'm very clear
that uh the referral process um has to
run its course
i think it would be premature to guess
what that's going to say i think it's
important that the expert resource that
we put in place
are able to do that job and that cricket
scotland are then able to own the
outcome and be very clear about what
they they do about it so
i would like to leave it at that for now
because i think this has been an
important piece of work people are
trusting
of the process
and i would like that to continue so
i would want to put this in place you
probably noted that my comments about
the referrals were right at the top of
my comments
on the mechanics of where we go from
here and i think that's critical going
forward i can only repeat what i said
james okay we let the process take its
course and let's make sure if there are
apologies required they can then be
given at that time by the people who are
responsible
uh ollie dickinson from st
you talk about holding cricket scotland
to account but many would argue that
this
is
you know after the review has happened
you were
the national agency for sport this was
happening directly under your nose how
was this allowed to happen
as soon as
kazim and majid spoke we took action
we had
there is racism in society there is
racism in sport
we accept that we our job in sport
scotland is to to ensure that we work
with our partners
to try and get as many people engaging
in physically divine sport as possible
so
in recognizing the issue
and being honest and true to the words
of majid and chasm we've engaged in this
review what we'll do now is take this
forward
as i said earlier on what's important is
what we do now there are lessons to be
learned across
all of the actions and i think it's
important that we
all take take those very seriously do
you accept it maybe took
too long and that it's a shame that it
took the bravery of those two gentlemen
to speak out to lay bear what is
relatively
how would secret seemingly i would put
it a different way i would probably i i
i'm sad that it took them so long to
have the confidence to be able to speak
because
i think that's
account you may be disappointed if you
didn't create an atmosphere then where
more people felt they could
be called the cricket scotland didn't do
that um i think we've all got we've all
got a duty to create that atmosphere if
it wasn't
in place in this circumstance then
that's
not correct
we have to create that open and
transparent environment that makes sure
that people feel they can talk about
what they're doing what they expect what
their experience is like
and have that assessed and acted upon
stephen gordon from bbc you obviously
have a large
number do you think that the problems
uncovered in this report are unique to
cricket and i'm just going to follow up
on james's point about an apology i mean
as a representative of scotland we do
apologize on behalf of that organization
so um
you have to remind me about the first
part of the questioning yeah
so
again i'll just i'm repeating a bit of
what i said um what what we will do now
with with the
recommendations is have a conversation
tomorrow with
ceos and senior staff of as many sports
as we can gather together
we will
put the lessons in front of them we will
ask them to have a look
at what's happening in their sport
and whether they would assess that they
need to take action that will address
that
i think any other way would be would be
preempting that i think we have to take
people as a national agency we have to
take people along with us and we need to
make sure that they
assess the situation that's in front of
them i think there are lots of lessons
to be learned from this this report into
cricket and cricket cricket scotland and
cricket in scotland
at the times are you just mentioned as
racism society embrace them in sport
is this a wake-up call for other sports
or under your umbrella
again i'll state that very clearly we're
going to have a look at it and we will
use this report
to illustrate to highlight
the potential pitfalls if if this is not
looked at closely
our core
our core aim is that we
um from an equality develop
an edi perspective
we try we try and engage as many
communities as we possibly can across
the country to do that we need everyone
to be aware of how to be inclusive
how to
encourage people to come along and have
a great experience at sport they all
deserve that and i think it's important
that we just take the time now
to sit down with cricket scotland in a
very
forward planning
mode to address the issues that are in
the report
but immediately use
the lessons that are in there to speak
to every other sport and on the
referrals uh how many referrals were
made to the police how many to join with
us
uh luigi
yeah
in terms of detail we're not we're not
going to share that detail but but the
rest of job refills have been made to
the police and children first
apologies for that only haven't just had
the detail we haven't
seen all of it
alex alexandra bbc magic hack sent that
text in 2015 receiving
so it's taken since then to get here so
we do not say it's taken too long and
also the board of cricket scotland as we
know resigned yesterday with the media
effect saying that they couldn't put
this into place within the time scale so
how doable is it likely to be with a new
board
it has to be doable
and this is this is where our
accountability function has to be
balanced with our development function
so we have to help gordon and in the
interim to put in place
the measures that will begin to address
this on the referral side we will have
to have a look at whether that's part of
that and cricket scotland
know a lot about the magic hack
situation so we need to just see what's
what's required to be done going forward
from here
and in terms of it being too long since
2015 you're saying we got here quite
quickly but from 2015 to 2022 was quite
a long time yeah but magic spoke out
very publicly um
just earlier in the back end of last
year so we're now addressing those those
issues and we're taking them forward
that includes magic in kazakh
heather
stewart do you think this is one of the
darkest days in the history of scottish
sport
yes i do
i think it's
a really difficult moment um
but i'm hoping
uh as i've said in many of my words
today that
we learn the lessons we're able to
address
a lot of the
issues that have been erased and i use
we because it's from our perspective
there's qriket scotland sports scotland
and the sport community all of us have
to address
address this
so i mentioned earlier on heather that
what we all do from here is really
important
and the
recommendations that are contained in
the plan
will be implemented our action plan will
actually plan them with gordon and his
team we'll look at the resources
required for that we'll talk to other
sports about their situation and how
they might look at what they're doing
so that we don't have a repetition
of this situation
and obviously we've spoken about the
funding potentially being pulled is
i'll be really clear this this is a last
resort and many
journalists
people i've spoken to
have asked me this question it is a last
resort we have in the past
taking that action it's very rare
and only happens in
very difficult circumstances
now's not the time to pull funding from
cricket because
we need to work with them
the development function again
we have to work with them in order to
achieve
what people
achieve answers to what people have told
them and i think that's really important
to
to put at the top of
the entry really
steve uh steve scott from knight
given all of this went unseen by you and
seen by school what guarantees can you
give that you can be trusted
we're going to learn all the lessons
that are in this report as well i mean
we we feel that we have
a good partnership with many sports
across that we invest in particularly
i'm very confident that the organization
having learned the lessons from this
report will be in a good place
to prevent this happening
again and to work with our partners to
better prepare
national governing bodies regional
associations local clubs
to be much much more welcoming and if
things go wrong to be open and
transparent about dealing with it
there is no other option
i think we have to do
your relationship with the sports that
you
fund
that this is going on
with this
thing
yes it's a failure um and we will have
to as i said look at ourselves our own
processes
steve um and look at how that happened
in the context of cricket because
our awareness of the
diversity of the cricket community
um
it's very visible
but we certainly were not aware of the
depth of challenges that was that are
now apparent
and we will work as hard as we can
to address those
bearing in mind that there were
significant feelings within the
board we saw the complete resignation of
the board yesterday and does that
government governance of cricket have to
be sorted out as well i mean i'd also
like to ask you about something that
said yesterday and castle shape but
the ceo um
was an issue at quicken scotland as well
so
you must have known there must have been
awareness of what was going on
to some degree before this was revealed
or certainly uh major hack and kasem
shake spoke about institutional racism
um
we recognized there were
some challenges
our our relationship
you know either we cannot
micromanage every sport
there are too many for that it's 50 plus
sports that we invest in
we have a strong partnership management
manager relationship
we
have to
trust in that to an extent but
whenever
we have something that is brought to our
attention we will deal with it and we'll
deal with it if it's a difficult
conversation that's required then we'll
take that conversation
and conversation on um and i think it's
important that we will review all of
those relationships we'll review those
mechanics we'll look at the audits that
we put in place that
should have potentially looked at this
and brought it to our attention
uh and i make an absolute commitment to
that
and just going back then to the comments
from amaran he's
he said yesterday that he would like to
see a castle shake um and uh
potentially going on to the board when
it's created what would your response be
to that
let me give you a slightly wider answer
to that i think we need we need people
from the community that contributed to
the review to be part of the future
we need all communities in in
involved in the game
to be part of the leadership and
governance
of the sport and that's a general
comment across across the board
i've spoken to chasm
a number of times personally
i think he's got a lot to offer but many
other people will as well
so i
you would be pushing an open door with
me if it was my decision but
unfortunately it's not my decision
but i i do think
as i've said earlier on the communities
need representation they need to be able
to be part of the leadership of that
sport and they need to be able to talk
openly and freely as part of that
process
how is the culture of bullying going to
brazil it's mentioned in the report is
that consider the closed book after just
makai's resignation
uh or is that something that still needs
to be looked at and you think it's more
than just an issue at the top of the
organization
uh again let me be clear there's not
such a thing as a closed book um as far
as i'm concerned
there have been a number of issues
um around
leadership that were unsatisfactory
actions being taken and we move on um we
one of my colleagues john one spent
three or four months working with
cricket scotland
he spent the majority of his time trying
to repair and rebuild the confidence of
the staff that's another job that we
take on willingly um
but again just to reiterate there's no
such a thing as a closed book we'll work
with the staff the rebuild conference we
will ensure
with gordon and his team that our new
culture is built that does not have that
element to it which is completely
unsavory and unsatisfactory so from my
perspective i probably can't answer that
any more strongly than that we need to
do at the top of the organization
i don't have that detail but
for me and this is a generalism
when you have issues around
culture
a huge responsibility sits at the
governance and top echelons of
leadership
please just one more um
you obviously set out the 31 areas for
the test for institutional racism were
you
surprised when an organization
fails on 29 of those and and essentially
fails on the other two
as well
i was very surprised
yeah i was very surprised and
we developed those indicators
separately to the consultation so that
didn't
muddy the waters if you like of the of
the conversations that we were having
with people we weren't going seeking
information that would back up those
indicators the whole process was
completely separated through the through
the independent review i was very
surprised
to hit 29 of the 31 is significant
and
and is why our recommendations at sports
scotland put them straight cricket put
cricket scotland straight into special
motors
i'm just finally stuart who is obviously
carried out this review into cricket
scotland specifically given the concerns
that have been mentioned here and that
you've acknowledged about relationships
with other sports that you look after
would you invite her to put those same
31 tests any other organizations under
the sports scotland umbrella to give
people a peace of mind across sport
scotland that the organization is doing
everything it can
we have a good relationship with losing
our team and we'll certainly have that
conversation going forward
can i just add to that i think
i think the indicators are a brilliant
opportunity for any sporting body in
scotland or perhaps even further afield
to have a look and
genuinely decide how do they map against
those indicators it's an opportunity to
really look at themselves in depth
i just want to sorry i just wondered if
you had i know
do you have one message
for all those victims
of racism out there
who are
engaged in scottish caribbean uh and
have been victims
who've come forward enormously
the message again is to thank them for
having the courage to do that
i would also ask them to trust us
to see that through to conclusion and to
make sure that in future people have the
confidence
to speak out
as
a normal function of a relationship or a
membership or an engagement and
involvement with a sport
i think
i'm humbled by the fact that people have
taken the time to do that because
um it has been a difficult thing for
them to do and i'm sure
many of them have really struggled with
that and i thank them most sincerely for
for taking that time you're asking them
to trust you do you think that's going
to be
difficult
i'm asking them to trust me
we
through this process i asked them to
trust me i think they have we've got to
this point i'm now looking forward and
i'm asking them to trust us again
i'm very clear about that and i hope
that they will do that
i'm going to take one last question
before we break for broadcast
has anyone offered them a direct apology
i've spoken to chasm a number of times
as i said and have a good conversation
with them
i'm kind of repeating the
the answer i gave earlier callum i would
like to see a process put in place which
properly examines
what's happened
to learn some lessons and if apologies
are required an apology should be made
by the people that are responsible for
that i think it's important
from
again until i know what some of the
issues are i think we we have to see
those referrals through
to understand what the issues are i mean
i'm sorry to keep labor on this point
but i think it's important we can't just
make snap judgments louise has just
talked about a
point framework which assesses
whether an organization may or may not
be institutionally racist i think we
have to give it proper
consideration
keith daniel